o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
Olá você fala inglês Teoricamente
existem duas opções de resposta para
essa pergunta sim ou não muitas pessoas
vão responder que sim que já atingiram a
fluência desejada se aqui se é possível
e outras pessoas vão responder não não
tão bem quanto eu gostaria não estudei
por vários anos e não consigo falar não
entendo que as pessoas dizem eu até
entendo muito bem mas eu não consigo me
comunicar como eu gostaria eu já estudei
e tantos anos já comecei o livro Um
tantas vezes e não consigo falar inglês
é com esse grupo de pessoas com segundo
grupo que eu gostaria de conversar um
pouco mais hoje bem eu falo inglês
fluentemente e e me dedico de alimente a
colaborar para que outras pessoas
atingir o tão desejado nível de
influência que aqui isso é possível né
Eu estudo inglês há muitos anos mais do
que eu gosto admitir e ainda não atingir
o meu nível desejado de influência creio
que isso não é não seja possível
a gente estuda mas a gente quer
aprofundar mas a gente quer saber enfim
mas essa minha caminhada dos estudos da
língua inglesa é bem existe um linguiça
senhor Jeremy Renner um linguiça
britânico que eu sigo E aí os livros ele
escreve materiais de aprofundamento o
profissional para professores de língua
inglesa e um dos livros mais famosos
dele ele disse que não se sabe ao certo
como se aprende uma língua estrangeira
ou uma língua em sim é isso é um balde
de água fria né para quem está no
caminho de aprender a Como se ensina no
entanto apesar da gente não saber
exatamente como as pessoas aprendem a
língua a gente sabe como as pessoas não
aprendem existem alguns fatores nessa
nessa nessa jornada do aprendizado de
uma língua aqui que não colaboram muito
para que para que o aluno chegue com
tranquilidade e sucesso ao seu objetivo
mais rapidamente e um desses
Essa é a questão de que se joga muito
com o medo EA vergonha de se falar uma
segunda língua Esse é um dos pontos
principais que no meu ponto de vista
prejudicam o andamento da pessoa o seu
desenvolvimento está língua e eu vou
falar um pouco sobre esses dois aspectos
hoje com vocês apesar de a gente não
saber como as pessoas aprendem a língua
eu sei como eu aprendi a língua inglesa
e como que foi que eu aprendi a língua
inglesa eu nos meus 17 18 anos eu caí de
paraquedas no curso técnico em
secretariado e na grade curricular
daquele curso existia uma a disciplina
de língua inglesa e eu simplesmente me
apaixonei pela língua eu não tinha tido
antes contato com o estudo né do inglês
em escolas de idiomas somente na escola
regular e eu simplesmente me apaixonei
eu ficava encantada com a professora
Falando a língua com o tipo de palavra
que soava como música
o seu simplesmente iria adquirir Aquela
aquele conteúdo para mim também eu
também queria falar daquela maneira eu
eu queria me comunicar com eles com uma
professora ou então compreendeu que era
passado nas atividades de áudio eu só
queria participar eu queria que aquilo
fosse parte de mim também então ao ponto
principal que eu acredito que me ajudou
muito a aprender a língua foi o querer
aprender muito mais do que necessidade
de aprender porque naquela época não
tinha nenhuma demanda na minha vida que
fosse o que fosse que usasse né da
língua inglesa então eu eu simplesmente
fazer as atividades quando o prazer de
fazer porque eu achava lindo eu achava o
máximo Quando eu conseguir falar uma
frase quando eu quando eu aprendi uma
nova palavra e assim eu fui caminhando
aprendendo até que me tornei professora
mais tarde em quando fui fazer minha
primeira viagem internacional eu já
tinha já tinha certificações
internacionais vem esse não é o pão mas
o que que
o olhar falar com vocês aqui hoje é esse
essa questão da Necessidade e do querer
então quando estava aprendendo a língua
inglesa eu queria que ela fosse parte de
mim e quando eu atendo pessoas hoje que
estão na sua busca aí de aprimoramento
da língua eu escuto muito a palavra eu
preciso eu preciso porque eu botei uma
entrevista de emprego eu preciso porque
eu vou viajar não que a gente deve
deixar as nossas demandas de lado da
vida né gente mas a gente precisa fazer
uma reflexão sobre eu de fato quero
aprender a língua inglesa ou estou
estudando a língua inglesa porque eu
preciso porque já tinha um abismo de
significados aí Entre esses dois verbos
que a gente precisa sempre tá de olho
ver se de fato a gente quer aquilo aqui
a gente está se dedicando a gente tá
fazendo simplesmente pela necessidade né
externa e não vem não é uma coisa de
dentro enfim nesse nesse aspecto existem
dois momentos na existe momento do
estudo na sala de aula ou em
se você quer pessoa pode estudar e
existe momento de prática fora da sala
de aula às vezes no seu trabalho você
tem oportunidade de conversar com alguém
você encontra um estrangeiro enfim ou
nas suas viagens né então vamos falar um
pouquinho sobre esse momento quando você
está em contato com alguém fora da sala
de aula é o que que passa pela sua
cabeça quando você tá conversando com
alguém em inglês você tá de fato
tentando entender as palavras que são
ditas as expressões que são faladas ali
naquela conversa ou você está pensando
aqui na sua cabeça como eu não posso
entender essa pessoa como é que pode
depois de tantos anos eu estudando eu
não consigo entendê-la Mas que ruim que
é o meu inglês mas que ó não vou não
consigo me comunicar E aí já parou a
pessoa já falou três frases e você já tá
fora não não acontece mais a conversa
e este é um dos pontos que eu percebo e
é muito prejudicial quando a pessoa vai
tentar se comunicar em língua inglesa e
tá estreitamente ligado à questão da
vergonha da Vergonha de se expor é
ninguém quer nem gosta da gente de
passar vergonha uma são os adultos nós
sabemos que o quanto é difícil no
entanto essa questão da vergonha ela só
existe dentro da nossa cabeça porque a
pessoa que está tentando se comunicar
com você ali do outro lado ela não tá
preocupada com se você sabe se você não
sabe inglês se você já estudou dez anos
ou não Ela quer a comunicação e todas as
pessoas deveriam se preocupar em
compreender o que está sendo dito em
devolver uma resposta à altura né e não
não ficar com a sua atenção aqui na sua
mente sobre o que eu que eu já estudei o
que eu não estudei porque quando eu sou
desgraçado Por que não sei falar a
língua não esse esse é um ponto que
pense comigo se a sua cabeça está a sua
energia
Oi tudo de volta a esses pensamentos
Como que o pobre do seu cérebro vai
conseguir te mandar as informações do
que precisa ser dito na hora da conversa
Então esse é um ponto é um ponto que eu
gosto de chamar atenção das pessoas
Preste atenção nos seus pensamentos ou
aliás Ignore os seus pensamentos
enquanto você está tentando se comunicar
em inglês é outro ponto é a questão do
julgamento né quando a gente está em
contato com uma outra pessoa é a questão
do julgamento atrapalha muito porque às
vezes Além de usar com a minha atenção
aqui mesmo jogando eu estou julgando a
outra pessoa de fora pensa pessoa não
faz erro a como é bonita a pronúncia do
fulano ou como como tá a pessoa fala mal
no cargo superior é o meu gente isso não
faz sentido nenhum não colabora na
comunicação esse tipo de pensamento esse
tipo de julgamento e apura a gente fazer
esse tipo de julgamento que a gente tem
medo que as pessoas nos julguem tão
bom então se a gente começar até um
pouco mais de leveza na prática da
língua inglesa e contentar de fato se
comunicar tem tem tantos julgamentos a
gente consegue também se livrar um pouco
do medo de ser julgado porque a gente só
de fato tentando se comunicar e não
ficar pensando aqui tantas coisas que
não que não vem ao caso no momento da
interação Ok então além de disso da
questão da vergonha né
não existe um outro ponto bem importante
hoje em dia que são as publicidades das
escolas de inglês que jogam com essa
vergonha então tomem cuidado quando a
gente vê algumas propagandas por aí que
fazem cachorra no fato da pessoa não
saber fazer falar em inglês eu acredito
que a gente deve sempre não fizer dizer
ao invés de passarinho gente normal ao
invés de ao invés de envergonhar você tá
e já ganhar uma pessoa por ela não saber
a gente tem que ajudar as pessoas a
terem orgulho de já estarem tentando se
comunicar uma segunda língua a gente
falaram outro idioma é muito difícil não
é tão simples então ao invés de criticar
uma pessoa por ela não saber algumas
coisas na língua ajude essa pessoa ter
orgulho ou você mesmo é a Ju disse a ter
orgulho do fato de você já está
conseguindo se comunicar mesmo quem
nível mais básico em uma segunda língua
Isso já é uma grande habilidade
bom então existe Além da questão do jogo
da vergonha da sobre cidades existem uma
uma onda de professores digamos assim
redes sociais dizendo que não é mais que
necessário estudar inglês você não
precisa estudar inglês para ser fluente
ver aqui eu tenho nada do milagroso que
você vai praticar tantas horas eu
aprendi inglês assim é bom
Olá eu sou suspeita para falar né porque
eu aprendi inglês Estudando muito então
eu suspeito de tais pessoas e Tais
métodos porque eu não acredito que seja
possível a gente aperfeiçoar nenhum
nenhum tipo de habilidade na nossa vida
sem o estudo mas eu confesso que o que
não a gente não deve continuar fazendo é
o estudo das frases sem sentido isso de
fato não é necessário que se faça então
assim eu participei de aulas em um
método que eu precisava dizer a frase
vou tomar um exemplo aqui para vocês aí
doente every morning e o que que repetir
essa frase e tantas vezes e uma
determinado momento eu falei para você
também Professor eu não tomo Chá pela
manhã eu tomo café Então esse tipo de
repetição de frases sem sentido é que
faz com que estudar em vez de algumas
anti e sem e sem conexão com a sua vida
real esse tipo de estudo de fato e o
concordo com algumas pessoas que ele
deve ser pelo menos diminuído né mas
tudo o que diz respeito a língua inglesa
quando a gente tá nessa caminhada de
Desejo de
Olá tudo é válido que se aprenda então
se eu puder dar algumas dicas para vocês
eu vou eu posso dizer que a gente quando
está aprendendo uma língua de deve se
dedicar a a estudar a língua com
curiosidade com muita curiosidade tudo
que tem ali com relação ao inglês me
interessa falar quando eu tiver
oportunidade sempre tive uma
oportunidade de falar falar sem ter
vergonha né gente fala deixa a vergonha
de lado ignora ela se tiver medo com a
nossa amiga Lena diz vai com medo mesmo
afinal de contas com medo sem medo que
importa se a comunicação aconteceu e
você não pode perder uma oportunidade de
se comunicar com alguém que fala essa
língua como Nativa e lembre-se você é a
pessoa que tem a segunda língua e
nenhuma outra pessoa sente pouquinho de
orgulho vai que você já aprendeu isso é
muito isso vai te ajudar muito nessa
caminhada da aprendizagem ignore o que
você pensa a respeito do seu nível
afinal de contas quando a gente viaja a
gente não pergunta para outra pessoa ó
qual que é o seu nível de inglês aqui
o intermediário eu sou do aparelho
permite assim então com você não vou
conversar não faz sentido nenhum a gente
fica aqui pensando que a gente fala
inglês base vai esquece tudo isso tiver
alguma oportunidade de se comunicar
entra na conversa e se comunica da
maneira que você conseguir quanto mais
você fizer esse exercício Mas você vai
perder o medo de se comunicar mas é
necessário que você tenha coragem de
começar a se comunicar sem medo eu gosto
de fazer um paralelo com aprender uma
língua ou uma outra habilidade com a uma
criança que aprende a andar quando
criança vai aprender andar Ela não fica
pensando assim a Olha lá meu pai como
anda põe o pé primeiro o calcanhar
depois os dedos na frente porque senão
vai ficar feia a caminhada não que que
nós faz levanta se perguntando dado
alguns passos cai algumas vezes depois
chora um pouquinho se levanta de novo
algumas vezes não já anda de fato de
primeira é a criança ela vai andando
porque ela quer mandar
É porque ela quer amar e aprender uma
segunda língua a gente é como uma
caminhada a gente vai caminhando e vai
aprendendo um pouco mais a cada dia e
vai ter mais curiosidade vai se soltando
um pouco mais vai se expondo um pouco
mais e vai tendo mais consegue se
apropriar demais situações que você
consegue você dá conta de se comunicar
com mais propriedade e assim é um
movimento eterno que nunca vai terminar
Como eu como eu com coloquei no começo
não existe uma fluência infinita
desejada sempre vai ter mais para
aprender E e essa questão de se deixar
levar e dá uma seus pequenos Passos
esses pequenos Passos é o que vai te
levar a esse aí esse domínio digamos
assim das situações que você precisa na
língua inglesa e esses Passos São É uma
longa jornada uma longa jornada pela
através do Vale da Alegria em aprender a
Livre